medic  oh Jesus  what is that  we should go  millions of dollars worth of cocaine  fell from the sky this morning in  Knoxville Tennessee there's more this  out there they dumped it somewhere I'm  looking for my daughter's first is a  dangerous place hey Henry check it out  something got into it a deer Maybe  a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to  go and get it  no don't eat that don't eat that let's  see what kind of effect that has  [Music]  the bear it [ __ ] did cocaine  [Music]  freaking cocaine  bear a bear it was hey that's  inappropriate  you're safe Bears can't climb trees of  course they can  baby  [Music]  it kind of seems like the thing that  stays with the man forever  apex predator  high on cocaine  thought of it's mine  oh man  baby  and don't ever come down  thank you  we have such good luck in nature  [Music]